قصص مرعبة لا تعد ولا تحصى
تأتي من أوكرانيا ، العديد منها
تتضمن أطفالًا ، الصور التي
توشك على رؤيتها مزعجة ، سأحذرك ،
لكن من المهم أن
يرى العالم وجوه هؤلاء الأطفال
ويسمع قصصهم هذه صور تم
التقاطها.  في مستشفى الأطفال الإقليمي zaparija
، سمح الأطباء للمطبوعة
البريطانية التلغراف
بنشرها قائلين إنهم يأملون في
أن تترك الصور انطباعًا قويًا
في العالم عن أهوال الحرب
ولا سيما على ضحاياها الصغار الذين
انضموا إلي الآن لشرح هذه الصور
بمزيد من التفصيل  أحد
المراسلين في هذه القصة
الصحفية الاستقصائية تانيا كوسيريفا
تانيا هذه صور صعبة للنظر
إلى هؤلاء الأطفال في
منتصف هذا أكبر ضحايا هذا ،
هل يمكنك إخبارنا بقصصهم أولاً ،
أود أن تخبرنا عن ماشا
ولمجرد توضيح العنوان الرئيسي للقصة هو أن
ماشا عمرها 15 عامًا ، جسدها مكسور
ويقول الروس إنها مزيفة أخبرنا عن
كوكب المريخ  هكتار
، المشهد بأكمله الذي شهدناه
كان فظيعًا في كابوس ، لقد
دخلنا غرفة العناية المركزة هذه
في مستشفى زابوس الإقليمي
وكان هناك
ثلاثة أطفال
وجميعهم
مثل اثنين منهم
لم يكونوا في ضمير  وأه ماشا
كانت الوحيدة
التي تعرفها والتي كانت تتفاعل أه على ما
يجري أه
هي تستطيع أن تتحدث لكن أه
قررنا عدم إزعاجها ورأينا
فقط تعرف هذه الصورة القاتمة لصبي
صغير جدًا
وفتاة أوكرانية جميلة تبلغ من العمر 15 عامًا فقط
ولكن قد
بترت ركبتها اليمنى بالفعل ساقها اليمنى ،
أعني بترت فوق الركبة
وأيضًا تمزق يدها اليمنى بسبب
الشظية التي دخلت
أحشائها وماشا
لدي  لإخبارك أن ماشا من بالوهي
هذه بلدة صغيرة
بالقرب من
زابوسيا وهي بلدة لا يوجد بها
مساحة ولا توجد بها عناصر عسكرية
وقد أصيبت بشظية بداخلها
في جسدها بينما كانت تتجول
حولها  البلدة مع والدتها لذلك قامت
والدتها بتغطيتها من الشظية
بها أم كما
أخبرتنا جدتها القصة
القصة هذه القصة الكئيبة
أخبرتنا أن
والدتها غطت
ابنتها
ولكن عندما علمت عندما
استيقظت رأيتك تعرف
ساقيها
نعم
ومثل هذا ، أنت تعرف هذه الصورة الخضراء جدًا
وعندما تحدثنا إلى الجدة أم إلى
جدة ماشا
كانت
تبكي فالنتينا إنها تعلم أنها
محطمة أعتقد إلى الأبد فقط لأن
اثنين من
أعز
أفراد عائلتها
أصيبوا بهذا الجرح إلى الأبد كما تعلم